today I'm gonna walk you through the
hype behind data science in healthcare
and then we'll talk about the reality
what the reality is really like and then
we'll dive into some solutions that my
team has come up with to try to navigate
health healthcare or a data science in
healthcare and then we'll speculate
about maybe some future directions of
data science in healthcare
so before I start is there anyone in the
room that works at IBM okay well I'm
gonna apologize in advance if I offend
anyone so let's get started with with
with the hype so here's I'm gonna go
through some some headlines here IBM
Watson is better at diagnosing cancer
than human doctors so this is from 2013
and IBM Watson may provide a shortcut to
treating cancer and then here's another
person you might be familiar with in the
machine learning or deep learning space
here's a quote from Geoffrey Hinton we
should stop training radiologists right
now in five years deep learning will
have better performance and that was in
2016 so we're a little more than two
years in now and Andrew aim he said in
relation to some work that his his group
was doing a Stanford should ready I'll
just be worried about their jobs
breaking news we can now diagnose
pneumonia from chest x-rays better than
radiologists all right so let's let's
talk a little bit about the reality so
this is more recent news Watson can't
cure cancer or all the stuff that breaks
IT projects University spends 62 million
on AI trial gets usual trials that come
with failure I actually think the in the
end it actually ended up being
more than 62 million dollars that they
spent on that project some cancer
treatment recommendations from IBM
Watson were unsafe report finds and then
talking about replacing radiologists
this is from a radiologist / machine
learning researcher I've spent several
weeks exploring the chest x-ray dataset
and I have some serious concerns with it
so that's the data set that was used by
Andrew Aang's group and he followed up
with the data set as defined currently
is not fit for training medical systems
and then there was this other doctor who
is also doing some similar research he
said now today more comes from the
Stanford group guess what the deep
learning method sucks it's much worse
than the radiologist no way and ruing is
trusting his own diagnosis to this
algorithm and this is actually like the
published results from the Stanford
group and it shows you know if you look
at the bottom line there the overall
performance of the model is worse than
the radiologists that they tested
against I mean he says you know what
else sucks when high profile machine
learning people oversell their results
to the public it leaves everyone worse
off because how can us mere mortals
publish a paper if we haven't rented an
entire profession obviously with our
results so some of you may be familiar
with this xkcd our field has been
struggling with this problem for years
struggle no more I'm here with I'm here
with algorithms wow this is a really
hard problem so moving right along to
the reality so this is a another vocal
doctor on Twitter Eric Topol he said he
did an analysis a summary of 12 papers
and he's pointed out that all of them
are retrospective some of them have
statistical methodological issues
we've yet to see prospective validation
studies in real-world clinic in the real
world clinical environment so this is
kind of an important point he's making a
lot of these papers haven't really been
tested in the real world to see if they
actually perform the way that they claim
to perform and here's another tweet from
him
the first fda-approved device to
diagnose diabetic retinopathy without
ophthalmologists know with no published
data and they make some claims on their
website about the performance in the
model but there's really no way of
verifying it
another common issue in in health care
this is a article written in the New
York Times recently about dr. Bernal
more than 50 so in the article they say
more than 50% of physicians the United
States have at least one symptom of
burnout and they point out that the EHR
has become the the electronic medical
record a large electronic health record
has become the symbol of burnout so
speaking you know a little bit just
about electronic health records they're
designed to replace paper records and
they're designed very much just like the
paper paper records for focusing on on
billing purposes and at least in my
opinion not enough thought had has
really been given into how computers can
help improve things they're often yeah
one-to-one mappings to the existing
paper systems and as someone who has to
utilize these enterprise clinical
databases I find the design design of
the database is awfully complicated
there's a lot of empty unused or seldom
used tables and in these databases and
there's no often no real clear guidance
on what table what particular tables are
used for the data the databases are not
append-only
which means values get overwritten so
there's and there's also often no
indication of when a value was written
so there's really no way that you can
use these clinical database systems to
reproduce what did the patient look like
at any given time
and then there's then there's some
interesting messy human data issues so
what would you expect to see if you were
looking at a temperature field in a
medical record probably you know
temperature and Fahrenheit
maybe the patient's temperature in
Celsius maybe something about how the
temperature was collected you can
collect temperature in various ways this
is the type of thing that you often that
you can find in the temperature field in
the medical record on unable unable to
take a temperature pacing just ate ice
or pate you know patient feeling hot
like I have a fever
deferred temperature reassessment
patient recently sipped sipped water ice
ice water so you might just think okay
like let's just throw out this weird
data but that may actually not be the
right solution because a patient chumina
on ice actually could indicate that they
have a form of anemia so it's not always
obvious what to do with this this weird
messy human data all right so let's
let's dig into like some of the
solutions that my team has come up with
to like deal with a lot of these issues
so when I first joined the team a few
years ago we actually were housed in a
in a start-up space and there was a
start-up in this sharing this space with
us called active protect and they
developed this device which is a belt
that elderly people can wear and it has
these airbags built in to prevent them
from breaking their hips so you can see
you know here's a demonstration by one
of the founders of the of the belt in
inaction he's falling over the airbag
deploys and so he doesn't break his head
and so we were you know as a team we
were thinking about one of the projects
that we were currently working on which
was trying to predict patients that
would develop sepsis which is a type
type of severe infection and we were
thinking about how wouldn't it be great
if this sepsis problem was like more
like this airbag problem in this in the
in the airbag problem it's a completely
observable system so what I mean by that
is the device makes some prediction
about whether the patient is going to
fall or not and then the device if the
if it thinks that the patient is going
to fall it deploys the point of the
airbags presumably does not like cause
the patient to fall and so it doesn't
impact the actual outcome of whether
they fall or whether they don't fall
whereas the sepsis problem that we were
working with we're trying to predict
what patients were going to get this
severe kind of infection so that we
could prevent them from getting the
infection and the issues would that we
discovered with this is that it makes it
it made it very hard for us to tell when
the system was not performing the way
that we expected it to perform was it a
model or was it the intervention or was
it something else because we had this
unobservable system where we were
impacting the app that our model was
impacting the outcome our use of the
model was impacting the outcome we
couldn't tell where things were going
wrong so we use this like terminology
commonly is it an airbag problem or is
it a jet pack pack a jet pack problem
where the subs' is a a substance example
was a jet pack pack problem so is your
solution an air bag or a jet pack and
can you like rethink your your design of
your system to design it as an air bag
instead of a jet pack
so in the in the case of like IBM
Watsons example how can you tell how can
they tell if they're giving the patients
the right to correct treatment if
they're trying to use the model to
improve patient survival how can they
tell the model is wrong or if there's
something else wrong with the system
that their model is integrated into or
the intervention so is this a good model
how about this this is a confusion
matrix taken from this model so for
those of you who aren't familiar of a
confusion matrix in the upper left hand
corner that's your true negatives and
then in the upper right hand corner
that's your false positives in the lower
left-hand corner is your false negatives
in the lower right-hand corners your
true positives how can we tell this is a
good model if I deploy this into the
healthcare system how can I tell if this
model is going to have a positive
benefit so when outcomes are uncertain
the best decision is the one that has
the highest expected goodness so
expected goodness is the sum of the
probability of an outcome times the
goodness of an outcome so how do we
measure the goodness of an outcome so we
can develop these cost make matrices so
in again in the upper left hand corner
is the true negatives so the cost of a
true negative is in the in this example
is 0 and then we have our false
positives so if you have a false
positive you're going to apply some
intervention to your patient that they
didn't actually need so the cost of that
decision is the cost of the intervention
and the lower left hand corner we have
our false negatives those are patients
that you should have applied the
intervention to
but your algorithm did not pick them up
so that's the cost of the negative event
and then you have in your lower right
hand corner your true positives and the
cost is the cost of the intervention
plus 1 minus e times the cost of event
and so e in this case is the efficacy of
the intervention because you have to
assume that sometimes your intervention
is is not going to work for per patient
and so applying this kind of decision
theory we can frame our our predictive
models and in a way that allows us to
determine if we deployed this to the
health system would we expect it to have
a positive impact
so in this visualization you can see in
on the x-axis is the cost of the event
and there's some uncertainty around what
the cost of the event is there's also
some uncertainty around the the cost of
the intervention which is what is on the
y-axis and we can see that in the upper
left hand corner this whole black region
of the space that's the region of the
space where it doesn't even make sense
to apply model and also you shouldn't
even apply this intervention because
it's it doesn't make it it's not there's
it doesn't the cost is too high for the
intervention in the lower right hand
corner this is a space again where you
shouldn't bother with an algorithm the
intervention is so cheap and the the
cost of the of the event is so high that
it just makes sense to apply the
intervention to everyone don't even
bother with a model and then this space
in the middle or that with the heat map
that's the area where there's a benefit
there's a net benefit to actually
applying a model to decide who gets the
intervention and who doesn't get the
intervention so this doesn't just apply
to healthcare that you know you could
apply this to this type of decision
theory too to any type of machine any
type of problem where you're deciding
should we apply
machine learning model here or not and
another another finally another thing
that we've discovered working with
clinicians in health in healthcare is
oftentimes they come to us and they say
hey Mike can you predict this thing for
me so that you know we we can prevent it
but they haven't really thought through
okay once you know I my team once my
team creates a model for them what are
they going to do with this thing and how
how are they going to use that to
improve patient patient outcomes so and
and also like by the way what are they
what is the outcome that they're
actually going to measure so that they
know that they've improved things so
many let me let's try a plot let's like
talk through this for a particular
problem that my team has worked on so
many patients receive palliative care
too close to their last days and this
delayed delivery undermines the full
utility of the services for patients in
need so palliative care is a type of
service that is provided to two patients
both often cancer patients who might
need some help with you know pain
medications or those types of things but
also just patients who are nearing their
end-of-life and helping to make sure
that the health care system as a whole
understands what are the patient's needs
and that those needs are being met so
again sort of like following this Madlib
framework that our team has come up with
we would say if I knew which patients
have the most serious life limiting
illness I would make sure they receive
palliative care to ensure the care the
care team understands their goals so we
we actually did apply this this frame up
to this palliative connect project as we
call it and we developed a dashboard for
the team that allowed them to go through
the patient
sorted by their risk of mortality in the
next six months and they were able to go
through that list and make sure that the
the patients near the top a list were
getting palliative care so they actually
changed the approach that is
traditionally taken traditionally a
doctor would call for a palliative care
console based on the needs that they see
for the patient and we sort of like
flipped it on on it on its head in this
case the palliative care team was
actually calling the doctors for these
patients and asking them do you feel
would it be alright for us to do a
palliative care console for this patient
do you feel that it would be appropriate
and this is very much an airbag problem
because even though we're predicting the
patient's mortality we're not actually
trying to prevent the patient from dying
necessarily we're trying to make sure
that they're kind of caring needs are
met so what would I what would the
Madlib be for the radiology example I
don't know maybe if I could speed up
radiology results I could get patients
out of the emergency room quicker to
lower costs and improve patient
happiness I'm not sure but that's
something that I think you would want to
ask when approaching that problem so
well you couldn't use like standard ways
of like I'm measuring patient happiness
but also if it's purely cost that you're
looking at you could look at the cost of
the patients in the in the emergency
room so
oh the palliative care example so we
measured a lot of different outcomes
talk to me after the talk I'm just like
drawing a blank for a second yeah so
let's talk briefly about like where the
where I hope that the future of health
healthcare data science in healthcare is
going so this is actually a paper that
was released on in the New England
Journal of Medicine recently by some
collaborators of ours and they talked
about creating a patient feed for for
your patients and so they they talked
about a study that they they did were
residents subscribed to push
notifications and for their patients
medic medication explorations and they
found that doses of antibiotics that
that were missed were cut by 1/3 so in
this idea of like almost like a Twitter
for patients they sort of frame it as
rather than the clinician having to
remember to check the medical record for
their patients the medical records kind
of coming to them and informing
informing them that they need to take
some action there's also been a lot of
work around coming up with better
sensors for patients smaller sensors and
cheaper sensors so this is a sensor that
measures blood pressure
I believe it's actually placed on the on
the jugular and it's as you can see a
very very small sensor and one big issue
that we have with healthcare data right
now is that a lot of it is very biased
it's it's you know labs are only ordered
when are often only ordered when a
doctor thinks there might be a specific
problem
and you know the similarly a lot of the
data is is entered into the health
record manually sensors cheap sensors
would definitely potentially help with
this problem because if they can just
apply these cheap sensors to all
patients and maybe even people in the
outpatient setting then you're dealing
with a lot of that that collection bias
and then finally there there was this
other article that talked about how AI
will be applied in health care they
talked about assisting in monotonous
tasks treatment design my medical
records and AI chatbots but I personally
and I think a lot of doctors feel this
way I hope that AI in health care will
be used to help the doctor spend less
time in front of a computer typing into
computer and actually spending more time
working with their patients I can't
remember where I heard this but I was I
recently was someone had had mentioned
that the the types of jobs that won't be
automated are the types of jobs that
require empathy and they talked
specifically about you know doctors
being one of these cases so hopefully
the doctors will be able to spend more
of their time applying their empathy
unless their time entering data into a
computer and if you didn't get anything
else out of this talk I hope you walk
away from this talk with understanding
that algorithms don't heal people people
do and thank you
we have time for questions okay good
talk
given that doctors are not trained stat
train of math when you call them up what
kind of data do you give them to help
them make this decision sure it I would
say it varies a lot from project to
project but often oftentimes I think I
find that one easier way to kind of like
present for example model performance to
doctors is to say if you took this in
action on X percentage of the patient
population
what would the performance of be like
how many of like how many of the sort of
positive cases would you catch versus
just like a random a coin flip or versus
what you're doing now those so that's
like a nice kind of like simple way to
frame things but it depends on the
sophistication of like who you're
working with I would say
go over here hey thank you for your
presentation
so you mentioned calculating the net
benefits and you put it in a really nice
visualization from the confusion matrix
so I wonder in that calculation what do
you think of you know potentially
administering care to a patient that
doesn't need it and you know ultimately
resulting in some kind of damage with
that how do you put those things in the
calculations sure so the you know that
those those cost calculations aren't
necessarily like taking into account all
the costs you can model those costs how
are like the complexity of how you
amount of those costs can you can make
them as complexes as you as you need for
your particular application so for my
particular application maybe there's the
clinical team thinks there's very small
or no cost to applying the intervention
that particular intervention to a
patient who doesn't need it certainly
there's cases where that's not true so
you would want to just include that in
your in your cost calculations but the
the clinic team actually gives you the
like the mathematical cost of you have
the time you know you have to talk
through it in like and there's obvious
not never an exact science but the point
is it's it's a lot better than just
looking at an AUC and saying oh yeah
that's a good model let's deploy that
right so it kind of helps you get closer
to what's like what's the real cost
benefit to deploying this model into the
to the system yeah
hi how do you think you go about closing
like the hype gap in terms of like the
initial first slides that you showed the
hype gap or it reminds me a lot of like
the reproducibility problem between sort
of academia and let's go slum
practitioners well certainly having
people out there who are you know trying
to prospective who are trying to
prospectively apply these techniques is
I think is helpful having you know
actual examples of real-world
applications is going to be helpful for
helping to like sort of like close that
gap I think yeah he actually kind of
asked my question but I'll follow up as
another one in your experience than
working with clinicians that you are you
seeing more skepticism or our team's
reacting to the stuff that you're doing
given some of the quote-unquote failure
is that it recently and publicized I
mean I think doctors in general are very
skeptical but I think for good reasons
you know it's their licenses that are on
the line if their patients who are on
the line so I think it's a really high
bar as far as like doctor skepticism
goes but and I think the only way for
the way around that is to sort of you
know prove through rigorous like
application of experiment
experimentation that these models can be
beneficial so you have to find the right
partner is on the clinical side that are
willing to kind of like go through that
process with you and and you know hope
for the best I guess
hey great talkin did you uh comment a
little bit about like data privacy I'm
trying to acquire data especially in the
home focused kind of thing where there's
open source development and how
difficult it is kind of get this data on
how hard it is to get that data and hard
is to share and how its kind of change
the last few years
sure I mean there are increasingly more
and more open data sets like the x-ray
data set data set for example is an open
data set my team being embedded in the
healthcare system we have access to the
data for our patients and as long as so
so that you know it's obviously easier
for us then I don't know what your
background is but like if you're like a
researcher it's obviously a lot a lot
harder to gain access to data it's I
think it's an open question of you know
a lot of a lot there are a lot of issues
around the around sort of anonymizing
this this healthcare data and finding
techniques for for good techniques for
anonymizing healthcare data if you have
you know any experience or any ideas
around this I'd be happy to kind of talk
to you about it afterwards
so I realized that this question is
probably a future talk in itself but how
do you my experiences that clinicians
are rightfully very skeptical of any
model output especially if it can't be
explained well to them exactly sort of
like what the inferences is strong yes
and so how do you how have you sort of
tried to reconcile the fact that the
actual cool stuff especially on the
hospital side is using methods that are
extremely difficult to see what they're
doing it's not a legit regression yeah
it's interesting you know in our
experience oftentimes the the doctors
who are directly collaborating with us
the ones who are working to develop the
models they're far more interested in
its interpret eithe an like the
day-to-day clinicians who actually would
have to use this those types of models
in our experience anyway the day to day
clinicians who have to utilize these
models they just want to know is this
thing like is this a good model and
should we trust it and where is the
paper that says by the way when you
apply this model in this clinical
setting it has this benefit but but I do
believe that interpret E is is important
I think it's kind of an at least in my
mind and I my experience is kind of an
open question how important interpret E
is we have time for one more
so you've mentioned it's pretty bility
what algorithms are you using mostly I
assume you're not using a lot of neural
networks no I mean so if it varies from
project to project anywhere from
logistic regression to you no gradient
boosting models we've discussed unity
neural networks for some some projects
but we haven't actually found an
appropriate application for them yet all
right thank you Thanks
[Applause]